speaking of which what films of each era
do you think resonated the most if we go
back a hundred years so each decade
let's say which films resonated the most
with that time amongst audiences and why
do you think that would be maybe pick
five or so well suddenly the birth of
the nation was incredibly a sort of him
big in 1915 most of his kind of horrible
tell us now because the racial attitude
in that film is really reprehensible but
for people in 1915 who were looking back
at the civil war that was the 50th year
anniversary of the Civil War I guess
that film constellated their feelings
about that war and their country and so
that was really a monumental monumental
film I don't know Citizen Kane not
really i don't think that really did too
much a movie like Stella Dallas with
Barbara Stanwyck I think resonated
powerfully because he excel in her
performance of the kind of love and
mother who was never less frustrated i
think spoke to so many particularly
women at that particular time i think
that really resonated a film like gosh
High Noon 1952 resonated fantastically
powerfully because at that period when
people were involved with the McCarthy
era and you know attempting to
understand who would stand by you and
who wouldn't I think that film resonated
you know fantastically you know
breathless my goodness in 1960s for the
first time most of us saw breathless
that resonated enormously we couldn't
figure out why because we thought god
this guy doesn't even know about
filmmaking I mean is that matching shots
right miss cuts here but somehow or
other it had the verb and feeling it had
the
Stolte of its age and so those kinds of
movies it seems to me powerfully resumes
and I wouldn't necessarily continue to
resonate their movies that were real big
in their day that don't mean touch
anymore so they were a hit then but then
they fizzled yeah because i think that
they spoke the feelings of their time
and that's different than having a truly
great classic film like a Bergman or
Fellini or winter light which are about
eternal spiritual things and about
method quests and for some reason you
know talk to people forever 70s 80s 90s
anything of each decade that maybe spoke
that's a driver I think taxi driver
really resonated why um what about pie
actor I think about that character when
Robert Nero looks in the mirror and says
you talking to me he's nothing to me
because there's no one else here you're
talking to me I think that kind of
potentiate it out the spirit of it at
that time I think that was incredibly
sort of powerful film that that's a kind
of movie I think Fight Club certainly
did for the same kind of reason because
it's full angst and confusion and
conflict and vigor and energy so I think
both days that do speak out of their
particular moment our movies that you
know resonate for their time 80s what's
in Fight Club is 90s right yeah so 80s
what would we think Oh choose hmm you're
big haha yeah all wrong you know Forrest
Gump yeah horoscope but certainly
slimey's um that that kind of film um
I think movies that do however have some
kind of mythic heart or our movies would
stay
you